[Applause]
what's up guys we're pongfinity we're
kicking off the air with something
pretty extreme a lot of you guys have
asked us to play on a trampoline so
let's
jump right into it come on
[Music]
okay so we've made our own table tennis
table from a wooden board
and of course the ponfinity net
it actually looks like tables only
knitting nuts
another great use for the pong finishing
and voila
it's really difficult
you can move really fast from corner to
corner yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i've been jumping for one hour now let's
go play some trampoline ping pong
should be fun okay
it feels quite quite funny too
[Music]
i need a break
hey y'all come on
[Music]
oh
are you ready sensei i am is there any
rules
i feel like i'm going to lose this one
i'm gonna lose this one
it's like
that was just my tactic
[Music]
oh good
that's sweet
i got it well done
nice job
another great example of how you can use
the funfinity net
go get yours at pong2.store now mika
let's play
okay
try and get me try to get me oh
if not you then your racket
[Music]
you're ready for this email i'm ready
good match okay okay i see how it is
those hits ain't gonna do nothing me
that was an incredible save dude
look what are you doing man
[Laughter]
[Music]
is he alive i need a moment to recover
from that
okay it's time for a foam pit dive
battle let's go
i have a flashback
i don't know what you're talking about
[Music]
whoa coming
and that ball is lost forever maybe not
the best idea
[Music]
oh that was close
whoa whoa
otto you want a table you know this is
my kind of table tennis
i don't mind it either to be honest
[Music]
hahahaha got it put work wasn't really
on point
did it move a muscle
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
and that was pretty sick you have
promised the backflip so
i have promised about it
[Music]
how is this so difficult
the hardest shot of my life
he's going for a big big forehand
you had enough fun now
yes the champion
i thought you had me there yeah i didn't
use my
i think i'm gonna lose this one tactic
so i lost that but yeah
big thanks to rush helsinki for letting
us come to film this video and
don't forget to check out
pongfinity.store until next time